es ist so verrückt endlich kann ich mal
neues buch über tesla ankündigen tesla
oder wie ihre maske die elektromobilität
revolutioniert und es ist nicht nur ein
herzensprojekt von mir sondern auch ein
wirklich ziemlich spannendes buch denn
bei meiner recherche bin ich auf mehr
wie soll ich sagen
das worauf ich gestoßen bin hat mich
echt vom hocker gehauen die geheimnisse
hinter tesla hier verrate ich ein paar
vorab pixum science in future gibt es
dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's das war wirklich ein irres
projekt denn so glatt wie ist beim
schreiben lief sollte es dann nicht
weitergehen denn menschen die ihr ganzes
leben mit verbrenner zu tun hatten oder
haben die haben ein erhebliches problem
mit dem was ich herausgefunden habe
wobei besonders investigativ muss sich
für diese recherche nicht sein alle
informationen sind öffentlich doch die
autoindustrie die experten und
expertinnen aus diesem bereich der motor
journalismus der nimmt nur ungerne notiz
zum beispiel davon dass der abgang
skandal laut einer studie durch die
betrugs oft wer rund 10.000 menschen
leben gekostet hat das ist schlimm und
stellt die kritik an den umweltfolgen
durch die produktion von elektroautos
doch ein wenig in den schatten
und so zieht es sich durch das ganze
buch elektroautos sind mit abstand und
das was meine recherchen aus rein
wissenschaftlicher sicht ergeben haben
umweltfreundlicher sicherer und was
tesla angeht auch technisch
weiterentwickelt als herkömmliche
verbrenner und es sieht ganz düster für
die deutsche autoindustrie aus ja auch
nach dem jetzt sehr schnell elektroautos
von deutschen und anderen herstellern
auf den markt geworfen worden sind sie
sind technisch mangelhaft stichwort
horror fahrten ladeleistung und
reichweite das buch musste ich also
gegen eine menge widerstände
veröffentlichen aber jetzt könnt ihr
mich unterstützen
es ist soweit hier und am bbi könnt ihr
schon mal vorbestellen wenn es euch
interessiert was sich natürlich riesig
fände ich will hier allerdings auf ganz
konkrete verblüffende fakten in diesem
video eingehen rund um elektromobilität
die ich selbst so echt nicht vermutet
hätte beispiel energie verbraucht dass
elektroautos deutlich weniger treibstoff
verbrauchen als verbrenner
das ist keine neuigkeit der wirkungsgrad
bei einem verbrauch
er liegt im schnitt bei 25 prozent beim
elektroauto bei 90 prozent doch es ist
noch viel krasser während beim
elektroauto bei der stromproduktion mit
regenerativen energien und über die
ladesäulen kriegt man diesen strom
meistens lediglich leitungs verlust im
niedrigen einstelligen prozentbereich
entstehen sind es beim verbrenner
absolut eklatante verluste
beziehungsweise muss ein erheblicher
zusätzlicher energie aufwand betrieben
werden bis benzin oder diesel im tank
landen
laut dem amerikanischen ministerium für
energie sind es noch mal sieben
kilowattstunden pro liter sprit auf 100
kilometer strecke sind das bei einem
realistischen verbrauch von sechs litern
42 kilowatt stunden zusätzliche energie
die für ölgewinnung transport und
raffinierung benötigt werden das heißt
dass zum beispiel ein dieselfahrzeug
noch mal zusätzlich zu seinem
klimaschädlichen treibstoff die doppelte
energie eines elektroautos benötigt und
alleine 1,5 kilowattstunden pro liter
sind da der strom der in raffinerien
verbraucht wird also schon dieser strom
stellt auf 100 kilometer mindestens die
hälfte des stromverbrauchs eines
elektroautos da und dieser zusätzlichen
energieaufwand entsteht bei erneuerbaren
energien gar nicht und bei heimischer
kohle nur in deutlich geringerem maße da
kohle nur kurze wege transportiert
werden muss und die regenerierung
entfällt also
selbst wenn hohe kohle anteile für die
energieerzeugung verwendet werden würden
um elektroautos anzutreiben was nicht
der fall ist werden sie
umweltfreundlicher und dabei darf man
nicht vergessen dass bei der verstromung
von kohle ein deutlich höherer
wirkungsgrad erreicht wird als bei der
verbrennung von diesel oder benzin in
einem pkw also nochmal zusammengefasst
der gesamte energieaufwand eines
verbrechers für 100 kilometer liegt im
schnitt bei rund 94 kilowattstunden beim
elektroauto sind es zwischen 15 und 25
kilowattstunden das ist zwischen
viereinhalb und sechsmal so viel und wer
aufmerksam zugehört hat dem dürfte es
nicht entgangen sein
10 kilowatt strom werden dabei in
raffinerien pro 100 kilometer verbraucht
sprich wenn alle menschen in deutschland
elektroautos fahren würden gäbe es gar
nicht den bisher prognostizierten
mehrverbrauch er ist nur maximal halb so
hoch weil der stromverbrauch in
raffinesse
ihnen fallen würde und noch ein fakt
dazu der schon frappierend ist eine
studie hat die energieverbräuche
verschiedener verkehrsmittel untersucht
und das ergebnis ist ziemlich
verblüffend die bahn gibt an auf
fernstrecken einen energieverbrauch
vergleich bei einem elektroauto zu haben
indem lediglich eine person sitzt der
ice3 verbraucht laut bahn auf 100
kilometer strom mit dem energiegehalt
von 2,3 litern benzin pro passagier
das sind 19,94 kilowattstunden auf 100
kilometer umgerechnet aus dem eher
niedrig angesetzten benzin äquivalent
von 867 kilowattstunden pro liter geht
man von der durchschnittlichen besetzung
eines pkw in deutschland mit 1,46
personen aus dann sind elektroautos
immer verbrauchsgünstiger als fahrten
mit dem zug selbst mein model es liegt
dann bei etwa 14 kilowattstunden pro 100
kilometer und personen laut der studie
ist das einzige verkehrsmittel was noch
günstiger in der co2 bilanz ist als ein
elektroauto
der elektrobus und dabei ist der
durchschnitts energieverbrauch der bahn
mit diesen triebwerken dem nahverkehr
und so weiter gar nicht vorsichtig dann
dürfte das ergebnis wahrscheinlich noch
mal etwas anders aussehen nicht zu
vergessen dass die bahn zudem erhebliche
strommengen aus kohlekraftwerken bezieht
und noch ein fakt der elektroautos
gegenüber verbrennern zu überlegen macht
sie sind besser konstruiert verbrenner
sind nämlich sehr fehlerbehaftete
fortbewegungsmittel die dazu noch extrem
gefährlich sind da werden zum einen hoch
brennbare flüssigkeiten im fahrzeug
transportiert und dann noch zum brennen
gebracht beziehungsweise noch schlimmer
zum explodieren
da ist eine extrem komplizierte und
anfällige technik die dazu eben auch
noch gefährlich ist beim unfall geraten
sie schneller als e autos in brand was
auch immer wieder passiert elektroautos
hatten übrigens auch bei ihrem batterien
diesen konstruktionsbedingten nachteil
der ja inzwischen durch die thermische
trennung der zellen behoben ist stand
der technik ist dass sie wenn sie
überhitzen gegenseitig isoliert werden
bei diesel und benzinmotoren hat bisher
noch keiner eine möglichkeit gefunden
brände so effizient zu unterdrücken
batterien können jetzt nur noch brennen
wenn sie beschädigt werden was tesla zum
beispiel mit einer titanplatte von unten
verhindert die
das zerschmettert was sich den batterien
von unten näherte brenner autos brennen
also nach der bisherigen datenlage
deutlich öfter der faktor beträgt
ungefähr 45 dazu kommen noch zwei
sicherheitsrelevante nachteile während
dem elektroauto das schwerste teil die
batterie ist und im boden sitzt sind es
beim verbrenner motor getriebe und tank
und die sitzen so hoch und sind so
schlecht verteilt dass sie das fahrzeug
instabil machen
der schwerpunkt liegt deutlich höher
weshalb sich verbrenner autos leichter
überschlagen können für ein model s von
tesla ist das in sicherheitstests bisher
nicht gelungen die batterie verhinderte
das überschlagen der schwerpunkt ist
dafür einfach zu niedrig die straßenlage
eines verbrechers ist mit einem
elektroauto also kaum zu vergleichen sie
ist durch die schlechte verteilung der
gewichte deutlich unsicherer diese
fahrzeuge können den steuern kommen oder
ganz von der fahrbahn abkommen was nicht
selten passiert der audi tt oder die
mercedes a klasse muss nachträglich
modifiziert werden
damit das nicht zu oft passiert bei
elektroautos ist das alles kaum oder nur
sehr schwer möglich zudem haben
elektroautos eine deutlich verbesserte
knautschzone der motor vorne fehlt und
so drückt beim unfall kein riesiger
heißer klopps in den fahrgastraum dazu
bedeutet die technik der
verbrennungsmotoren einen erheblichen
wartungsaufwand ölwechsel riemen und
ketten die gewartet und ersetzt werden
müssen
ein verbrennungsmotor hat rund zehn mal
mehr teile als ein elektromotor die
meisten davon bewegen sich mit einem
minimalen spiel das unbedingt stimmen
muss deshalb verschleißen verbrenner
motoren deutlich schneller als
elektromotoren elektromotoren sind
weitgehend wartungsfrei
wie überhaupt elektroautos kaum service
benötigen viele teile neben dem motor
gibt es gar nicht oder sie werden viel
weniger gebraucht keine kupplung nur ein
einfaches getriebe keine kardanwelle bei
hinterradantrieb kein anlass der
auspuffanlage katalysator und so weiter
und so fort zudem halten die bremsen
rund 300.000 kilometer weil meistens mit
den elektromotoren gebremst wird die
dann als generatoren genutzt werden und
die energie zurück in die batterie
rekuperieren wie die rückgewinnung der
bremsenergie genannt wird bei verbrennen
müssen erstmal die bremsbeläge nach
spätestens 50.000 kilometern gewechselt
werden und später dann auch die
bremsscheiben das alles bedeutet zudem
einen erheblichen kostenvorteil werden
fahrzeuge mit verbrennungsmotoren
regelmäßig gewartet werden und ab etwa
100.000 kilometern deutlich mehr
reparaturen anstehen entfällt vieles
davon komplett bei elektroantrieben
tesla extrem pfarrer hans jörg eberhard
freiherr von gemmingen hornberg der mit
seinem model es inzwischen mehr als eine
million kilometer zurückgelegt hat gibt
die wartungskosten mit 1300 euro auf
100.000 kilometern also auf eine million
kilometer sind es dann 13.000 euro
der adac kommt bei einem verbrenner auf
rund 120000 euro auf eine million
kilometer wobei man verbrennen noch zwei
neuanschaffungen dazukommen dürften das
heißt für eine million kilometer in der
model s fahrzeugklasse müssten bei einem
verbrenner geschätzt 300.000 euro für
die anschaffungen ausgegeben werden +
wartungskosten von 120.000 euro
gesamtpreis 420.000 euro bei models sind
es inklusive wartung zwischen rund 100
und 160 tausend euro
das sind ein drittel bis die hälfte der
kosten es gibt also sehr gute gründe
warum der verbrennungsmotor im wahrsten
sinne des wortes zum alten eisen gehört
in kalifornien der fünftgrößten
wirtschaft weltweit wenn kalifornien ein
eigenes land wäre wird der verkauf von
pkw mit verbrennungsmotor ab 2035
verboten dort dürfen also noch neun
jahre lang verbrenner verkauft werden
dann ist schluss in der eu wird auch
über ein ende 2035 diskutierte und
andere länder werden folgen der
verbrennungsmotor ist ein auslaufmodell
an dem die deutsche industrie viel zu
lange festgehalten hat was ihr jetzt
großen probleme bereiten wird bmw ist
mit dem i3 und dem i8 mit werks
gestartet hat aber dann wieder die
elektromobilität ausgebremst der
volkswagen konzern hat das steuer
endlich umgerissen und auch zulieferer
wie zf bosch und continental haben
elektroantriebe ganz oben auf ihrer
agenda der rest dümpelt noch etwas träge
und uninspiriert vor sich hin und was
nicht vergessen werden sollte die
fossilen energieträger überleben nur
dank massiver subventionen je nach
berechnungen sind das 550 milliarden bis
5 billionen dollar pro jahr
so rechnet nämlich der internationale
währungsfonds der auch die schäden an
der umwelt mit einberechnet wenn auch
ein wert für die subventionierung von
erneuerbaren
nur schwer zu berechnen ist er liegt in
jedem fall sehr deutlich darunter und
jetzt haben wir ein projekt vor und ihr
könnt dabei sein wir wollen das buch die
bestsellerlisten bekommen und ihr können
teil davon sein natürlich nur wenn euch
das buch wirklich interessiert bestellt
es jetzt schon vor
dann haben wir eine chance das thema
wirklich bekannt zu machen und in die
medien zu bringen
dennoch wissen viel zu wenige über die
wahren fakten zur elektroautos bescheid
ich finde es wirklich super wenn nämlich
dabei unterstützen könnte also hier
klicken anschauen und bestellen
mal sehen wohin wäre das buch bekommt
der link ist auch in der video
beschreibung und im ersten angeboten
kommentar also vielen dank an alle die
dabei sind und ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran